[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です
ナイト
プール24時間生活ポンポンポン
読売ランドのプール
ウォーターアミューズメントアイランドと
いうナイトプールに来てます
暑いよついに24時間生活こんなにぬるく
なってしまったのかと
前回きつかったですから前回橋の上24
時間生活とかやってたので
夏っぽいということでナイトプールで24
時間生活したらどうなるのかちょっとやっ
てみたいと思いますそしてなんとすごいの
よ
貸し切りでございます
逆にどこ見ていいのってなっちゃうけどね
その水着の女の子がいないってことですよ
ねまあでも好き放題遊べるっていう
ガチのひとりぼっちのナイトプールの24
時間生活なんでだけど逆に人目を気にし
なくていいっていうちょっと
夏休みっぽくなってきたねですね今日は
のんびり一人でナイトプールで24時間
生活していきたいと思いますこれルールと
しては飲食はOK飲食とかはOKです
勝ちでも3時間ごとにサイコロはあります
ちょっと待ってくださいよそれもあるん
ですか
[音楽]
3時間後にちょっと教えてくれるって事ね
分かりましたちょっと見てみましょうか見
てすごいよ
めちゃくちゃ大きいのよ今俺たちが
えーっとここにいるんですけども今ここに
いるんですけれども見て流れるプールが
あったりとかもう空気も入れるんだねここ
で
便利だねそういえばさ俺たちよくその
浮き輪とか使ってさ企画やってるけど自分
たちの空気入れてるじゃん
便利だね
プールってガチで刺されるんだけどもう1
匹いるんだけどほら見て
もう始まってるからこれ
帰る頃にはね
これもこの宿題夏ならではの
蚊が多いからそこもちょっと今日の戦いの
舞台ですね
急にこういうねワイワイジャングルって
いうアトラクションチックなプールもあり
ますよとですごいダイビングプールとかも
あるんだスイミングプール
波のプールはすごい
wi-fiみたいでジャイアントスカイ
リバーすごいねこういう生きるんかな
貸し切りだからさすがにすごい
直線セラロームスライダースライダー的な
ねやつもありますと全部俺だってこと今日
全部いけない
いいんですかそんな今日
豪勢な
存分に楽しんでくださいありがとうござい
ますまたサイコロの内容わかんないから
どうなるのかわかんないんですけども最初
の3時から平和ってことね早速
遊びに行こうぜ
さあ始まります54321
俺の
[音楽]
家族は無事か無事ですというわけで18時
夕方ですねもうすぐ暗くなってくるので
ナイトプールになると思います18時から
明日の18時までどこまで俺行っていない
この施設内のさっきのマップに書いてある
やつのところなら全然どこでもこの
ゾーンであれば大丈夫ってこと
プールに入らなくて休憩しても大丈夫もう
それもまあ
楽しみ方だと思うんでなるほどナイト
プールで何か売店みたいのあるじゃない
ですかなんか
軽食とかさドリンクとかねそういうの置い
てあるから置いてあるものはいくらでも
好きなだけ
じゃないですか今日は
ヌルゲーです
じゃあ早速ちょっと回っていきましょうか
いいのまあ今まで過酷な24時間でした
からね色々かわいそう本当にあーすごいね
こうなんかラーメンとかも売ってるのね
すごい
秘密だ水しかないよもうここが流れる
らしいです
飛び込みだけはちょっと気をつけましょう
ね皆さん
貸し切りだとしても僕は守って今回使い
ますので見てすごいよバイバイジャングル
新しいやつですね
なんかもうどこらじゅうに水が出てるけど
カメラマン
マジで気をつけなよすげー
[音楽]
待って絶対見れるこれあの絶対絶対寝れ
ますねこれ
これもう絶対濡れるねあー濡れたあー一緒
にしたよもうなんか面白いな
おー勝手に落ちちゃったあーすごい
ビシャビシャ
水没してる船みたい
うわあちょっと待って待って待って待っ
てる
わかんない何が起きた
突然水が降ってくるタイプの
アトラクションで
おもろいわ大人も楽しめるとマジで
おもろい
[音楽]
程よい
速さですすごいちゃんと休めるスポットも
ありますねすごいな
わかってない
マジで
威力
圭佑の顔があるここでさずっとこうやって
てもいいってことだよね
それで明日の18時でも可能です
何でもいいです日中はちょっと暑そうだね
そうですねもうちょっと
プール楽しんじゃおうかないやーちょっと
怖いねこんな楽しんじゃって楽しんじゃい
ましょう
サイコロが怖くなってきましたはいこれも
楽しんじゃいましょうというわけで次は
ウォータースライダーいきたいと思います
読売ランドの
プール初めてなのでちょっと行ってきます
ねいいのこんな楽しい24時間生活楽しん
でくださいね
そろそろナイトプールっぽくなってます
行きます
[音楽]
スマホ大丈夫だった最高
隣もあるのでぜひ
結構ね
想像以上に勢いありましたこれやば
超直線行きます
これやばいわこれやばいわ待って
危ない
早くなかっためっちゃ早かったやばい
ちょっとおじさん疲れちゃった
休憩しました
もうすぐ1時間経過ぐらいですね気づい
たらね
面白かったちょっと休憩してからまた遊び
ますかちょっとここで休憩します
ちょっと深いわちなみに俺泳げない
泳げないのでちょっと浮き輪とかボール
使ってそこら辺の定番のプールで遊ぼうか
な
うまい
はい1時間経過しました
時の流れが遅いまだ1時間でしょ結構体感
も23時間たったと思ったんですけどまだ
1時間ですねこれねチルタイムだね
時間の流れが遅く感じましたちょっと
だいぶゆっくりできたので別のプール行っ
てみようかしら流れるプールがあるので
入ってみたいと思いますもうだいぶ夜です
ねよし行きましょう
あーすごい
[音楽]
流れてるなこれなんか
腹筋割れて見えてかっこいいな
[音楽]
2時間経過しました
やばいね体温が多分消えてきてるのもある
からちょっとプールにいるのはあんまり
良くないかもしれないですそう思ったら
もう全然
上がってなんかチルタイムでもそうだよね
ちょっと1回上がって休憩しようかな結構
で2時間しっかり来るのがいるとだいぶ体
が冷えました普通にプール行ったらバカ
疲れますからね体力がね流れるプールはね
水ってさ水流があると冷たく感じるから俺
今体温35度キューブなんですよ結構低い
ですね
楽しいのよ楽しいけど普通は2時間プール
泳いだら結構満足いくわあと1時間我慢
すればサイコロタイムか
基地と出るか京都出るかまだわかんない
から
楽しみにしててください
あったかいもんとか欲しいですか
お腹すいてますお腹空いてます
サイコロは待たないでお腹空いてますんで
それサイコロでも食わなきゃいけないって
ことあるかもしれないいやけどちょっと
体温上げたいからなんか食べようかなはい
というわけで結構
プールから出たら意外とあったまってき
ました24時間生活ということで
泳ぐだけがナイトプールの過ごし方では
ありません生活しますちょっとあの仕事を
溜まってるので
編集したいと思いますなかなかナイト
プールで動画編集することないからな
ちょっと貴重な経験ではある
[音楽]
ご飯かご飯持ってきましたよ
ご飯は自由なんだね黒い
液体飲みたいかもしれないですね本当に
いいのもう今日はナイトプールでもそうだ
よね食べて飲んだりできるのがないところ
ですから
ありがとうございます
いただきます
叫んでも誰もいないから
迷惑にならないこんなお客さんいたら皆
さんやめてくださいねもう誰もいないです
けど誰もいないから俺で叫んでるだけなの
でこれはちょっと勘違いしてほしくない皆
さんほんとプールなんか
楽そうと思いますけどなんなら一番体温
下がるので結構本当にカロリー入れて体の
熱出さないと本当に危ないのでちょっと
手巻き寿司とか食べちゃおうかなじゃあお
寿司いただきます
[音楽]
プールサイドで食べるご飯って美味しく
ない
プール入ると疲れるのよ体がきっとスキー
場で食べるやつと一緒だね
普段しないような運動をした後のこういう
休憩とかに食べるご飯が美味しいこれ
ナイトプルの醍醐味です本当に
誰もいないの誰かもう一人二人とか言っ
たら全然変わってきそう楽しさがでもそう
するとさすがに塗るかこの孤独との戦いも
きっとこのナイトブール生活のポイントな
んだろうないただきます
[音楽]
うまい
3時間経過しました
はい3時間経過しました感想としては全然
そういう秋田とかはないですマジで楽しい
ずっと水にずっと入ってる結構寒かったん
ですけどもご飯食べてそこは回復しました
ただねちょっと寂しいみたいなとこあり
ますね一人でずっとというわけで
最後のタイムです
始まりましたねよし運命の
サイコロタイムとりあえず何があるかを
知りたい今から行きますか1
女の子来ます
でも1時間だけです
3時間3時間だったら俺は喋れないよ
なんと
4人います
壊れちゃいました2
プールの中で3時間ちょっと待って
くださいもう1回聞いていいですか
プールの中で3時間と思います
まあでもなしは何もしなくていいから逆に
助かりますのんびり過ごしたい4はい
ピンクの悪魔
あの前に使ったじゃないですか
めっちゃでかいフラミンゴの
川で泳いでたやつ
持ってきました
遊び相手ができるということか
確かにナイトプールでそんなでかいよ今日
は使ったことないからちょっといいのあり
です
貸切でしかできませんから5こたつ
食べ物ルートです
もう食べたい引かなきゃ
もう食べましたさっきガッツリ
強制ですこれはもし出ちゃったらなんで
キング出たらどうすんだよその6を引か
なければいってこと行きます目標は1
女の子
欲しい
本当に本当に本当にちょっと待って本当に
これは1です
女の子
[音楽]
来てもらいました
逆に緊張してきますそれじゃあお願いし
ます
[音楽]
こんにちはよろしくお願いします
うわいい匂いやばいいいんですか本当に
[音楽]
皆さんは
遊んでくれるんですか
[笑い]
なんかまだ回ってないところとかあるんで
ちょっとそことか回りましょうか
じゃあ行きましょうかはい
[音楽]
ちょっと
人見知りですいません
[音楽]
そうですよね
来たことないですか
マジですか
わかりました俺も全然そんな行ったこと
ないんですけどすごい
美女を引き連れてる
ちなみにあそこに見えるのが
波のプールです
[音楽]
擬似的に海らしくて
緊張しちゃって話せないんだけど
全然後ろ向かないですだって
服がないもんいつも企画とかだったらさ
その
企画で割り切れてできるけど今回ちょっと
この
プライベート感
やや恥ずかしいですね自己紹介とか自己
紹介
ちょっとじゃあ自己紹介していただいても
いいですか
[音楽]
よろしくお願いします
今日はどこから来られたんですか
よろしくお願いします1回サウナの企画の
時いらっしゃいましたよね
[音楽]
ちゃんと
覚えてますはいよろしくお願いしますお
願いします
[音楽]
お願いします
よろしくお願いしますあなたもサウナでい
ましたよね
のぼせてます乗せてましたよね
楽しんでてください
行きましょうか
うわすごい
[音楽]
泳げない人
多分そんな深くないと思う
ちょっと
泳げない2人どうぞ
すごい
そうなんかあそこでライブとかあるらしい
です
[音楽]
俺に取られないように
頑張ってください
頑張ります
女の子同士でパスしちゃって逃げる
女の子買ったら何かありますか女の子買っ
たらじゃあえっと
水中に
5分潜りますよ54321
[笑い]
[拍手]
[音楽]
怪物がいる
[拍手]
[音楽]
マジで怖い
負けたー
[笑い]
じゃあちょっとということで皆さん5分間
潜っていただいて
趣味趣味趣味
[笑い]
なゲームです
好きで
メタル
音楽結構
尖ってる
んだけどね
何
[音楽]
回で
深い意味がないかとか
[音楽]
変な人ばっかりだなこれです
青いやつ
グルグルのやつと長いのがあって
そういうことまっすぐのやつです
ちょっと俺1回見本として連れてきますお
願いします
こういう感じかな
カメラ大丈夫誰か行ってみる
行く
かっこいい
行ってらっしゃい
行ってきます
[音楽]
美味しかったですか
美味しかったです
か
まだまだですね
全然まだまだちょっと俺が
しちゃおっかなじゃあちょっともう一回
持って行きますか
ちゃんと見といてね行ってきます
いいとこ見せるぞ3回目もやれば全然違う
からもうスピード感とか
あと1時間経ちました1時間経ちました1
時間経ちました
あそう帰っちゃったのか
もう帰っちゃったらね
楽しい時間はあっという間ですねまあでも
1時間でちょうどいいよちょっとコミュ障
だからマジで緊張したもしかしたらもう1
回引ける可能性あるじゃないですか
楽しかった楽しかった最高だねはい4時間
経過しました残り20時間ですじゃあ
ちょっとね女の子がいてくれたので
ちょっと心は
楽になったというか楽しかったんです
けれどもここから2時間はちょっと結構
遊び疲れたのでシュールな時間を過ごし
ますベンチとか探したいなどっかにないか
なあとめっちゃ綺麗だな
これはインスタグラマーとか来ちゃうね
ナイトプラーこういう装飾も含めて
素敵ですよねあーここめっちゃいい
ちょっとここでしばらく
休みます
やばい
[音楽]
雨が降ってきましたちょっと夜だから
分かりづらかったけど結構今日曇ってたの
ね雨がちょっと降ってきてはおりませんね
かなり雨降ってきているのでちょっと避難
しますこことかどうここどうですかいや
貫通して降ってきてるなどうしようかしら
波のプールのステージの所って言っていい
のかなちょっと行ってみるか
ここで雨宿りできたら最高だなはい着き
ました
ステージに来ちゃいました
ここで多分アーティストとかライブとか
するんだろうな雨宿りはできなそうだけど
このタイミングで雨が止んだので結果的に
セーフ
[音楽]
6時間経過しました
青いな日付が変わってしまいましたあのー
これナイトプール24時間生活と5つも
実質24時間全裸生活みたいなとこあり
ますねちょっと夜風が冷たくなってきまし
て
プール入るのもちょっと億劫になりそうな
状況ではありますはいというわけで3時間
ごとの最後のチャレンジしていきたいと
思います目標は
逆にこれだけを当てたくないっていうのは
プール3時間多分マジで死ぬそれのまま
リストは1できます
目標は1です女の子とまた会いたい
あるある
[音楽]
ここから3時間
行ってきます行ってらっしゃい
あーやばい
慣れれば行けますけどちょっとやっぱり
久々に入るの止めた青い部分に体が乗っ
てればそうですね水に浸かってる面があれ
ばかなと
わかりました
こんだけ要望があるんですけど
さすがにちょっと企画が過酷すぎて
寂しいので
健介とボール遊びすると
かってここの時間だけ3時間だけ
ありです
ちょっと入ってるんでちゃんとそうそう
ですけどビーチボールで遊ばせてよ
ガチでやばい
[音楽]
2時になりました
水中から
プールから出ちゃダメあと1時間で終わり
ですきつい
寒い寒いやっぱ夏といえでも夜風があって
結構寒くて水曜もねそのあったかいわけで
はないので結構体が芯から冷えてきて結構
厳しい戦いが強いられていますはいあと1
時間なので
頑張ります
[音楽]
終了です
見て見て見える
見えます見えますかねこれ
鳥肌なんですね
洗ってください
[音楽]
やばいやばいマジやばいマジ寒い本当に
寒いちょっと1回たっ倒れはいはいはい
ありがとうありがとうやばいこれは動か
ない
やばいやばいやばいちょっと待って本当に
1回本当に本当にやばいそうだねはい3時
から1回も出ませんでしたやばい全然
きついこのネジを時間かかるまだ
温水
プールとかだったらまた違ってたかもしれ
ないですけどしっかりあの冷たい気持ち
いいプールなのでそこそこ体力ちょっと
持ってかれましたねよし
サイコロいきましょうか
今日も今日とてお願いします行きます
寒いので
[音楽]
女の子女の子えっと
これは
44です
どうなんだろうなぁとりあえず水に浸かり
たくないって気持ちが強いのでちょっと
その上で痛いちょっと
休もうかじゃあ少々お待ちください
準備させていただきました
あれでかいからねかなり
助かるのかねどうなんだろうなぁどっちな
んだろう
久しぶりですよね結構
久々昔動画で使ったぐらいですからね
女の子たちも乗ってるんですけど乗って
ます
ぜひぜひ
[音楽]
じゃあ皆さんあれお疲れ様です
それはあれ入ってないです
届けに来てくれたんですね
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ました一緒に旅する
約束はしてないです
[音楽]
[拍手]
プールの中に入ってるのをきつかったので
ここでちょっと
ゆっくり休みたいと思います流れるプール
で横になってゆっくりしたいと思いますお
やすみなさい
もう3時過ぎです
[音楽]
えっと
デカすぎて流れに流れるプールにいるん
ですけどもこのピンクの悪魔がでかすぎて
流れないのでちょっと
古いとします
波のプールにピンクなんかも連れてきまし
たあと2時間ぐらいあるのでそこまで
こいつの上でちょっとお休みたいと思い
ますまだ一睡もしてないけどもう朝なん
ですよまだ波に揺られて寝るとしましょう
おやすみなさい
[音楽]
入れすぎて
[拍手]
[音楽]
12時間経過しました
ようやく折り返し地点です半日ナイト
プールで過ごしましたこれがナイトプール
と言えるのでしょうかもうナイトが
なくなってしまいました
プールですツツバチのプールになって
しまったんですけども一応ナイトプールの
朝ということでおはようございますこの
まま続けさせていただきます現在体感気温
はマイナス4°cさっきの3時間プールの
中結構聞いててこんな寒くはないんです
けどなんかすごい俺は体感寒く感じており
ましてちょっと
いち早くちょっと横になりたいなというか
十分な睡眠が取れてないのでちょっと今
睡眠の確保を最優先したいところでは
ございます最後のタイムえーと
狙いとしましてはあ先生4番がピンクの
悪魔も
ゲットしてしまったんですけどもこの後4
番どうなっちゃうんでしょうかやっぱり
ライトプールと言ったらアルコール
なるほど
らしいですね
今はいいかな狙いとしてはそうだなまあ
食べ物で体は温めるのも良しこたつも
ちょっとまさかのまさかのこたつが必要に
なる時が来たとちょっとあったまりたい
ぐらいの気持ちがあります
あとは一番女の子が引き続き狙っていき
ます絶対復活させたいところではあります
行きます来い1
やばいぶつかっちゃう逆にその力を利用し
てきた
やったー
ということでコツゲットですか
もう廃炉入ろう
準備しますありがとうございます
隣には
並みのプール私いるのはこたつもうこの際
温かいのであれば全く問題ありません最高
ですこの波ロックプールをバックにこたつ
の中でちょっと寝れたらいいなと思います
おやすみなさいちょっとあったかい
出れそうです
[音楽]
9時です
暑い背中がもうやばい
わかるかなこれなんですよ
ほぼ地面ちょっと休めましたけど思った
ほど出れなかったって感じですねだいぶ
助かりましたきついですもうお願いします
行きますよご飯ちょっとまだ大丈夫です
休みたいみんなプールあーちょっと厳しい
です
ね
眠いので一応女の子
えっ何て3は何もなしですおやすみなさい
[音楽]
12時になりました
18時間経過しましたあのー
寒かったんですけどやっぱ日中は暑い
ちょっともうね
プール入りたいぐらいになってきましたね
結構暑くてだいぶ体力も回復した気がし
ますねあと編集が捗りましたはい1個持っ
たんですけど5の形ももう出ちゃってる
じゃないですかどうするんですか
やっぱナイトプールなんで
アルコールで
意地でも飲ませに行きましたねナイト
ボールといえばそうですよねお酒まだ早い
なと6時間でしょうちょっと暑くなってき
たのでプール入りたいんですよ水着の
女の子もう1回来てくれないかな着替えて
たしね俺の狙いは
[拍手]
頼むよ本当に
頼むよ結構転がるね
[音楽]
はいもうすぐお昼なのでお昼ご飯食べたい
と思います
サイコロで食べ物ルーレットもあるからね
ちょっと
爆買いはできないんですけどうどんとか
ポテトとか売ってたものを食べたいと思い
ますいただきます
[音楽]
食べる食べ物が一番うまい
今1時半残り4時間半になりました
ちょっとご飯も食べたんでそろそろ
ちょっとお昼の運動しようかなご覧
くださいこの真上の
[音楽]
幼虫ひどすぎるだろこれね昨日まだ乗って
ない実は超巨大ウォータースライダー一番
でかいのまだ乗ってないのでちょっと俺
この後半に折れそうな心を元気づけるため
に残しておいたんですよちょっとこれ乗っ
てきますいってらっしゃい
俺これ登るの
結構高くないです次に該当するお客様はご
利用できません体調の悪い方
失礼しますお
酒飲む前で良かったお酒飲むと乗れない
みたいですねアイドルできてんのこれ
うわー今じゃなかったあとサイコロ1回
あるもんねそれで女の子出したらまた来
ますわ店員4名だから1人漏れちゃいます
女の子たちのためにも予行演出してくるわ
待って待って高いぞこれ結構これ高いの
苦手な人厳しいレベルの高さだないやいや
高い高い
[音楽]
ああこんにちはよろしくお願いします結構
高いですね
赤いところ
行ってきますこれちょっと
ちょっと
後ろ向きに何もわかんないけどこれ
すごいなおいすごいぞ
気持ちいいだろう
ありがとうございます
おもろいこれは
ウォータースライドの直線よりスピードは
なかったんですけどアトラクション要素
強いんでこれは女の子と乗って間違いない
やつこれだわそれこそ乗りたかった女の子
と絶対しましょうね
[音楽]
[拍手]
まさかの後半で太陽が出てくるという
戻りましょう
30になりました皆さんこのナイトプル
生活はあと3時間になりましたもう
建物に入ってみたい建物に入りたいよ24
時間1回も建物に入ることなく
服を着ることもなく24時間ずっとこの
プールナイトプールにいましたマジで
女の子と遊びたい心から本当に
いるよねまだいますよ
本当にこれで当てないともう本当に俺で
さっきリハーサルしたのよあれ俺
リハーサルしたのよもうさっき
さすがにいいとこ見せてね最高のナイト
プールで終わりたいと思いますいきます
狙いは一番女の子のみ最高のナイトプレイ
で終わりたい
頼む頼む
ええやだやだやだ無理無理無理無理無理
無理無理無理無理無理無理無理無理無理
無理無理無理無理
ダメです
何だっけこって
元々なんだっけなんか違うと変わったやつ
だよねもともとはこたつでしたじゃあ
こたつ入りますいやダメですナイトプール
といえば女アルコールですお酒お酒まだ
また今度また今度やればいいじゃないです
か
ラスト3時間でしょ
頑張ったお祝いに飲んでもいいのかもね
今日ぐらいは
お酒お願いします女の子が良かった
やらせありなし女の子が良かった
これも女の子見たかったやらせあり
あれナイトプールに乾杯
いただきます
プールで伸びるこんなおいしいのかこれ
あんなにプールで飲んだことなかったから
ちょっと感動的な大きさですね
罰ゲームとかではないですそのなんか
たくさん飲むとかそういう好きなだけ飲め
ます
[音楽]
始めた
終わりました
[音楽]
[笑い]
24時間終わりました
[音楽]
いやー楽しかったよかったです楽しかった
けどもうやっぱ何だろう
プールってだけで体力の生まれ方が相当
すごかったですね後半サイコロ振って2と
か出して3時間プールとかだったら俺は
マジで多分ドクターストップでしたはいと
いうわけで紐隠れてきましたね無事に24
時間1日ナイトで生活しました
もうちょっと女の子と遊びたかったなんで
ナイトプールの深いところまでその夜中は
どうなってるのかナイトプールの夜中寒い
です日中ナイトプールはプールになります
暑いですもう寒いまま暑いまま味わった
あの一見楽しそうに見える企画でしたけど
後半もうほぼ死んでたでしょあれ寝てるん
じゃなくてもう休んでたのよ動けなくて
なかなかねやはり24時間生活するとなる
とナイトブルでも大変なことが分かりまし
たでは
素敵な夏だねでもいい思い出になったわ
ありがとうございますじゃあまた別の24
時間生活でお会いしましょうバイバイ
[音楽]